hi this is presh talwalkar
how many triangles do you see in this
picture
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
we need to count the number of triangles
very carefully
we'll first consider triangles which
have a size of four which means its side
length is equal to four times the
smallest triangle
there's exactly one triangle of this
type and this triangle is facing upward
let's continue counting only the number
of triangles which are facing upward
let's count the number of triangles
which have size three
in the bottom row there are two of these
triangles and one row above that there's
one
so that makes for a total of three
triangles of size three facing up
how many triangles are there size two
facing up
the bottom row has three
the next row has two
and one row above that has one
three plus two plus one is six
finally we count the number of triangles
of size one facing up
the bottom row has four the next row has
three the next row has two and the top
row has one four plus three plus two
plus one is equal to ten
now we need to count the number of
triangles which are facing down
we'll start by counting the number of
triangles of size one
the bottom row has three
the next row has two
and the row above that has one
three plus two plus one is equal to six
now we count the number of triangles of
size two facing down and there's exactly
one
now as you can see this is the largest
size triangle that's facing down so
there are no triangles of size three or
four facing down
so we've now listed out all the
triangles and we can total this up to
get that there are 27 triangles in this
picture
now what would happen if we want to
generalize this for a base that has n
smaller triangles
well we could we have we found a pattern
in the shape we just saw
the number of triangles facing up of
size n the largest size was equal to one
the next size there were two more of
them
the next size there were more of them
according to the shape
each time we were adding the next number
in the sequence these are the triangular
numbers which are the shapes you can
form
that have a triangular arrangement of
shapes and they're equal to the sum of
the numbers from 1 to n
the triangles of the smallest size 1
were equal
to the triangular number of size n
now in many videos we figured out the
way to sum up the numbers from one to n
and this is the triangular formula
number which is equal to n times n plus
one over two
to count the number of triangles facing
down we start from the triangles of size
one
this will be offset by one
so we start out with triangular number
of n minus one
to get to the next size of two
we have to offset it by two because each
time the row is decreasing in size
so this is going to go about halfway up
and then the largest two sizes many of
the largest size we're going to have
zero triangles facing down
so now we figured out a pattern and how
to count the number of triangles of each
size and we have a formula for the
number of triangular numbers equal to n
times n plus 1 over 2.
so this actually going to vary whether
you have n equal n is going to be even
or n is going to be odd but there's a
nice way you can summarize this if you
add up all these numbers
the total number of triangles is going
to be n times n plus two times two n
plus one all over eight rounded down
this will give you the number of
triangles it's actually a sequence
the number of triangles formed if you
have
this equilateral grid of triangles the
sequence starts out 1 5 13 27 was what
we had when we had four triangles in our
grid it continues 48 78 and so on
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon
you can follow me on social media at
brushtellwalker if you like this video
please check out my books there are
links in the video description